les camions s'arrêtent, ils continuent leur
route jusqu'au Dakota du Sud, oh
vraiment, vous êtes proches de ces dessins sur le
terrain, ils ont l'air vraiment
soignés, ils sont là pour
l'érosion du contour afin que l'eau
coule dedans et et euh et dirige
le r  là où ils en ont besoin oh Le donc
ils sont faits par des hommes
mm c'est vraiment
graphique, il y a des gars là-
dedans qui travaillent dans un domaine, vous voyez que
oui, il est tout seul dans ce grand
domaine La Mélodie du
bonheur Je me demande si c'est à quel point
c'est abordable  c'est pour qu'un agriculteur local
ait une moissonneuse pour qu'il puisse le faire. Je pense que
nous sommes fondamentalement à court de travail,
où avec tous ces modèles,
nous sommes en dessous de nous ouais comme ça comme
ça, il ne reste plus celui qui me reste plus de
9  :00 ok là-dedans oh il y a des
courbes de niveau là-
dedans non non non non où à gauche en haut en
bas euh en bas
ok là à gauche ouais très bien ouais ouais euh je pars
pour No Man's
Land je cours toujours ok arrête
d'enregistrer
encore  oh
ouais ça fait tourner les cultures
ok celui-ci là-haut ils font
ressembler au drapeau français
ok
ouais sois
carré oh ils sont là-haut, ce sont
eux euh ceux après à droite ouais
cette ferme ça ressemble à un ok ici
vraiment mince  Les rayures dont tu vois parler
ouais je les ai mais mets-les euh
Square comme ça ces stes ici et
attends que nous arrivions en ligne en ligne
ouais pourrait aller dans la bonne direction
ouais ouais laisse aller toujours
parfait comme d'
habitude je pensais que je '  J'ai fait une erreur mais je me
suis
trompé
et j'ai tiré pour que nous puissions le faire, donc je me
suis
bien comporté, ok, ok, allons-
y